but Vlad you're talking about nurses  thank you thank you thank you  John Krasinski strikes again he does  indeed and we love these stories where  folks are faking our first line  responders medical professionals so some  nurses who happen to be diehard Red Sox  fan got the very best gift ever John  Krasinski surprised them with legendary  player David Ortiz who then had another  huge surprise take a look the Red Sox I  got ad or name or ticket for life  they're like what so after that big  surprise the group was then given a ride  to Fenway Park on a sanitized duck boat  once they got there they headed out to  the field where the entire Red Sox team  thanked them on the video board Anthony  gotta love it you know I'm a Mets fan  and even I know how awesome that is  really for life yeah you're right Gail's  right John Krasinski strikes again that  was really really awesome  they deserve it they absolutely deserve  it it's such a great gesture all right  thanks Vlad